surprising development in America's
immigration crisis almost no one saw
this coming Crossings at the border with
Mexico are down more than 50 percent
since the policy known as title 42 ended
last week they had been expected to go
up I mean way up the numbers are still
very high and detention facilities are
overcrowded on this side of the Border
President Biden himself told Americans
to expect chaos but for now the Crowds
Are calm Administration officials say
that's because strict new rules that
went into place when title 42 was lifted
are working but Republicans say the
numbers are still too high and
unacceptable